if you want to be able to have seemingly
unlimited godlike powers without having
user crimson bailet or a normal Bailey
and therefore having to sacrifice one
for your loved ones then I suggest you
hit the subscribe button and turn on the
Bell notifications that way you're
notified when a new video pops up on
some of your favorite hiatus infested
series hello and welcome to the new
world reveal source for everything anime
and manga and yes this is indeed the new
out review and the individual you heard
in the SUBSCRIBE intro was the masked
man who we will hear from a bit more
later because we are here to talk about
small Berzerk quite specifically in
regards to one of my favorite antagonist
groups in all of media being the godhand
now these guys are a very unique set of
beings and storytelling and they evoke a
feeling within me that I have rarely
found in any other tale they're the kind
of antagonists who command power Terra
and respect almost entirely through the
mere act of being because the absolutely
crazy thing about berserk is that the
godhand with the exception of femto of
course have never really done much in
the series and to compound that they
almost never actually appear in the
series either yet at the same time their
presence is felt in every panel of every
chapter as if it was burned into my mind
like a brand of sacrifice on a black
swordsman and the way that my aura has
handled this group is nothing short of
masterful I think that a lot of lesser
authors would have very much dropped the
ball with characters like these because
there is a very delicate balance to
maintain especially with the layer of
mystery and macabre intrigue associated
with them and that's where the power of
these characters comes from the fact
that we've been told that they are more
or less the epitome of demon kind and
reside on a level of power so great that
we as an audience and never really
allowed to actually explore it instead
we find ourselves acting very much a
struggle as along side guts with brief
glimpses into a realm that quite frankly
we may never really have any real
comprehension of and as frustrating as
that may sound those sorts of pieces of
lingering intrigue is what leaves a
lasting legacy finding out too much
about them or their abilities but going
even further and say managing to defeat
them would be very much the equivalent
of having the technicalities of a magic
trick revealed to you it would be
interesting and all but you will always
feel underwhelmed by seeing that trick
performed in the future so in many ways
godhand works best by knowing as little
as possible because our collective
imagination is probably much more
powerful than anything New York could
tell us about them on a page at this
point anyway now with that said after
all of the praise I've given to the
concept of mystery and minimal use that
in and of itself is not quite enough
because we as read
and watches do indeed need something to
latch on to a piece of connective tissue
or a letter of introduction if you will
and Miura does provide that in the form
of the latest member of God hand being
femto Griffith and his journey really is
the key to everything with this group
because the Golden Age ark more or less
provides us with the background and
process we need to know regarding how
one ascends into a position of power
within the berserk realm and seeing
Griffiths journey to become femto gives
us that solid grounding we need as an
audience because as a human we can
strongly identify with Griffith to a
certain extent and that connective
tissue carries over into the despair
full layer of power that is the god hand
and not only that but as interesting as
the idea still is it also almost
nullifies the need to find out how the
rest of these beings came to be because
we can make the appropriate inferences
that over the course of history there
were humans corrupted and ambitious in
the same way that Griffith was and that
plays on the imagination granting
endless ideas regarding what kind of
person say slan was when she was human
was she some sort of sadomasochistic
queen like many of history's most
notorious female figures or is it the
exact opposite was sland subject to the
cruelty of one of these figures and over
a lifetime of torture did that simply
warp her mind to embody the very concept
of lust upon her eventual transformation
and that's just the obvious example
because Sloane maintains more of a human
form most of the time anyway when you
look at beings like say void and it's
just like what deep recesses of humanity
could have possibly spawned something
like you and it's great because as
separate is the god hand off from
humanity in terms of power there is that
direct link to them in terms of their
origins
they aren't like demons born from a
separate race or anything they're just
hyper evolved humans who have gone down
an incredibly dark path but the thing I
love most about God hand in berserk
is that they don't even need to properly
appear to evoke a threatening and
sinister response there have been times
in berserk like the climax of the
conviction arc where you just see the
very basic forms of the members and even
that is enough to make you go oh damn
I'm not sure if I want to be here right
now or even further on in the series
where you see a simple page like this
and you just know that this is void
because his design and presence is so
distinct that you gaze upon brain matter
and that in and of itself is enough to
convey the presence of a God and member
and there's also something quite
humbling regarding the idea that these
entities may not necessarily see an end
in the
Cirie's as it stands the power
difference between them and any of our
protagonists are so out of this world
that it would take something like guts
or maybe Casca ascending to the status
of God hand themselves to effectively
combat them in any way but at the same
time that whole idea just doesn't sound
very berserk like to me if anything it
feels like the series will end with the
conclusion of guts the story and the
entirety of berserk will exist as a
snapshot of time which the god hand
exists prior to and following a tiny
glimpse of the world kind of like human
existence in our reality but here's
something even more terrifying and it's
the fact that the god hand aren't even
the be-all and end-all of existence in
the story even discounting the events of
the lost chapter the Godhead are
referred to as the executives of an even
greater being which adds yet another
layer of intrigue this already
ridiculously captivating group of
antagonists and to delve a bit deeper
into what we actually do know about this
group I have invited youtuber slash
bazooka file the masked man onto the
channel to give some history and his
take on the god hand yo how's it going
everybody is the masked man and I'm very
glad to be here today to talk about my
favorite series of all time berserk and
more specifically the big bads of the
series the god hand now the guy hand are
a very interesting bunch considering how
mysterious they are within the world of
berserk despite them being the major
antagonistic force within the world of
berserk we know close to nothing about
them just like calcium boy the skull
Knight there's very little known about
their past and most of his just
speculation and theory with bits and
pieces given here and there by different
characters throughout different parts of
the story however due to some of the
interactions of the god han and the
skull knight we do know that void must
have had some connection to the skull
night in their past and it is believed
that void was the first user of the
Crimson Bailey the Crimson bailet is
used apparently every 260 years
therefore the god hand weren't all
created at once but if not each was
chosen every 260 years in a ceremonial
event known as the Eclipse we see this
as characters like Zod at times points
to the Eclipse is going to happen again
this time referring to the fifth and
final member of the Guardian which ends
up being Griffith and so as for the
actual order of all of the godhand
members again it's something we don't
really know but from what we do know we
can say that void was the first chosen
and Griffiths was the final member
chosen of the god hand and so outside of
Griffith who ends up becoming femto the
final member we don't really know the
origins of the
got Han members or as to who they
sacrificed why they sacrifice and what
their true intentions were now I think
that the majority of the group's origins
being left a complete secret and unknown
to this point is great thing in the
story giving that it seems to add this
mysterious factor to them and it makes
them a little more creepy leaving all of
this a mystery really does add another
level of intrigue speculation and
interest to their characters being that
again they are the biggest villains so
far in the story of berserk and I
believe the biggest question we usually
ask ourselves about a villain in the
first place is how did they become a
villain and so Mira leaving that up for
speculation that we have something to
think about during hiatus is what we
call a pro-gamer move and so the
characteristics of the godhand based on
their origin is very difficult to say
however the characteristics are still on
full display while they are godhand
members currently and so before I get
into kind of describing each member of
the god hand and what they've kind of
done in the story so far let me list
them out for you real quick
we have void Ubik sland Conrad and femto
as I said earlier void is believed to be
the first user of the Crimson bailey and
he's known to have most connections with
the skull knight from what we see of
voids characteristics he's very good at
speaking and as the skull Knight says he
does it in a very preaching manner he
definitely seems to be the big brain of
the group get it and as for character
design he's definitely the most
outstanding member in the group
well other than slán but for completely
different reasons and I think the
godhand as a whole and more specifically
void it seems are put into picture
perfectly with the iconic quote is the
destiny of mankind controlled by some
transcendental entity or law as I like
the hand of God hovering above at least
it is true a man has no control even
over his own will and so as for voids
purpose within the story along with the
rest of the god hand is they seem to be
key manipulators of the flow of
causality in a way they're kind of
manipulating the course of history for
their own benefit and as for what their
final goal or plan is again we don't
really know and so void along with the
next member Ubik seem to be the key
talkers of the group doing most of the
manipulation as we see towards Griffiths
character leading to his downfall when
he becomes femto and so as for Ubik you
Vic has the lamest character design of
all the godhand but again as I mentioned
him and void seem to do most of the
manipulation
Ubik pointing more towards the emotional
sides of the people that way they give
in to using the bailet or in Griffiths
case the Crimson
and if I'm being completely honest
that's probably the most I can really
say about you Bix character and so for
the next member konradin ride is the one
we hear speak the least out of all of
the members but from what we see of his
abilities he seems to be really good
with diseases and plagues and so yes
Conrad is responsible for covin 19 and
so now we move on to the most um eye
catching member of the got hand slant so
it kind of describes lands
characteristics she is kind of the
goddess of this orgy loving cult and uh
well you kind of have to play a
masochist a sadist and an extremely just
will say hi driven person together to
get the overall feel of house land
behaves she has this obsession with guts
his character and she even seems to find
some pleasure when he drives his sword
through her and I'm not using that as a
metaphor like this man put his giant
honk and Dragon Slayer through in
between her anyways point is a slant
character can easily be associated with
the word lust in fact so much so that
the skull not used probably the most
sophisticated way of saying the word
thought by calling her the princess
horror of the uterine sea however we do
know because of slan that the god hen
are able to use physical manifestations
in the physical world however outside of
just physical manifestations the godhand
are bound to the astral world now ever
since the great roar of the astral world
where the astral world which is where
the god hand abides and the physical
world merged that could very much be
different now and so before I get into
the final member of the god hand I
should probably elaborate on that and
expand a little bit being that again the
god hand are responsible for a lot of
the things that ends up happening within
the story of berserk by again using some
of these physical manifestations and
manipulations of people within the
physical world to further their plan and
so the biggest example of manipulation
and using people in the physical world
this is where we get into the final
member of the God Hand Griffith or well
femto now I really don't want to get
into Griffiths character because that
could really be its own video but long
story short and forgive me for
simplifying it but Griffith was somebody
who wanted his own Kingdom he's on the
road of doing so he accomplishes great
things and then his best friend leaves
and he sleeps what the princess gets
caught gets tortured for a year and now
he's a mutilated husk of his former self
and so he falls into despair and in a
last-ditch desperate attempt to regain
his dream again he sacrifices all of
them
members of Hizb and any raves guts his
girlfriend Casca in front of his very
eyes in other words griffith did nothing
wrong is a load of crap however since he
did become the fifth and final member of
the god han just like the other members
he was now bound to the astral world
however through some more manipulation
of god hand it was made a possibility
for griffith to be brought back into the
physical world through the incarnation
ceremony and so now Griffith is given
this new physical body while also
keeping all of his God hand powers so
now he can go and accomplish his dream
without any of the human restraints
whether it be physical or emotional and
he does when the kingdom of Falco Nia is
created and so as for the god hand
despite us knowing very little about
them their presence is more than felt
within the world of berserk the majority
of the group being left a mystery is
great for speculation as well as having
a character like Griffith who is now
femto who is one of the best antagonists
ever written
again balances out the group perfectly
and the fact that they make very few
appearances within the story of berserk
just adds a more importance to when they
actually do appear and just add on top
of that they seem to have some
incredible abilities as we see when
femto bends space and so essentially in
conclusion the god hand is one of the
most formidable villain forces i've seen
in manga and all of us Brizard fans
would love to know the origins of a lot
of these members but if it's left a
mystery I think that also really does
play into the story as well and then you
have it really supreme power supreme
mystery and supreme tera all wrapped
into one little neat five-part package
that really in my opinion is a huge
factor that elevates berserk beyond the
average manga it's definitely not
everything not even close but I would
personally credit the godhand as the
feature that engrossed me into the
series when I first started reading
berserk an awfully long time ago now I
remember not being too fast or impressed
by the opening chapters and it really
did take something like the summoning of
the God hand to properly open my eyes
and engrossed me into this world without
those figures present very early on in
the series I'm not actually sure if I
would have continued on into the golden
age' or indeed if we began with the
Golden Age arc I'm not sure if I would
have been intrigued enough to pursue it
which would have been a great shame
because berserk in general got handle
know is a superb tale that has this rock
saw the group fan tagging us with a
permanently overbearing presence over
all of existence and that is the kind of
glue that binds together the already
incredible elements of the manga to me
so to conclude this glorifying fan
boyish video only
to say is that Muir absolutely nailed
this and these characters will stay with
me until quite probably the end of my
brief existence on this world but what
do you guys think please to leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more berserk Ian's content
then please do go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for hopefully regular brutal
berserk brilliance delivered straight
until YouTube beat but for now this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]